my argument is not based on the idea
that we should love animals or have warm
feelings to them it's based on the idea
that this is a major ethical issue a
major ethical wrong that we are doing to
those who are not members of our species
it's nearly 50 years since you first
published animal liberation
why we release the book now
well apparently because it is nearly 50
years and although I did revise it in
1990 that's still 33 years and the book
isn't just you know Timeless philosophy
it has some of what I hope is timeless
philosophy in it but it it's applied to
the real world and the Real World
includes industrial animal production
which is a vast industry that is
terrible for animals to Planet climate
Health everything but it's changed of
course that industry has changed over
the last uh 50 or 33 years I also talk
about the use of animals in Laboratories
and I described experiments that were
done the last time I revised the book so
experiments from the 1980s not very
relevant if you want to know what's
going on with animals in Labs today
so those are two main reasons
um lots of people ask me about well you
know has have we made progress for
Animals over the time since you wrote
Animal Liberation
um I wanted to answer that question uh
and I did want to talk about climate
change and its relevance to our choice
of what we eat because that obviously
wasn't in the 1975 Edition I had no
knowledge of climate change and it was
barely in the 1990 Edition either
what ways do you think we've made
progress with regards to animal welfare
and in which ways have we gone backward
we've made progress in restrictions on
some of the worst forms of
close confinement of animals in
industrial animal production that I
focused on in the earlier book so for
example
laying hens egg laying hens were in very
small wire cages where they couldn't
even stretch their wings even if they'd
only been one hand per cage they
couldn't have stretched their wings
fully but there might be four or five
hens in those cages they have been
prohibited in some places so they've
been prohibited in the European Union
the United Kingdom has maintained those
prohibitions after leaving the European
Union uh some states of the United
States where citizens can bring
initiatives to the ballot and have a
vote on them California is the largest
of those States uh have also restricted
those cages and as well individual
stalls for veal calves and SARS where
again they couldn't turn around the
stores were so tight they could hardly
walk a step
so there are some places where those
things have been banned another big form
of progress is that there are many more
vegetarians and vegans there were
virtually no vegans when in 1975 when
the book was published there are now I
think supposed to be 1.3 million vegans
in the United Kingdom and varying
figures for the United States that uh
some some surveys go much higher than
that in the US so you know there's
greater awareness of animals and the
idea that animals might have rights is
no longer a matter for ridicule as it
was when the book first came out so
there's lots of um ways in which we've
gone ahead
the big way in which we've gone
backwards is that there are more animals
in industrial animal production now than
ever before and that's at least partly
because of the rise of China and the
fact that China has become a lot more
prosperous you know which is great we
don't want people to be in extreme
poverty but um so hundreds of millions
of Chinese now use the extra income that
they have to buy more meat and China has
been building these enormous factory
farms like 26 story buildings just full
of thousands and thousands of pigs
obviously never getting to go outside
just living their entire lives on the
concrete floors of these buildings
uh and because of that uh and you know
expansion of other chicken production uh
fish factory farming aquaculture as it's
called to nicer word for what it really
is
um
you know so there are far more animals
suffering now from Human abuse than they
were in 1975. I suppose that the
increase in human population just means
that there is a greater requirement for
food so even if you've had an increase
in the proportion of people that are
eating vegan or vegetarian there is
overall a significant more number of
people who are eating full stop and
regardless What proportion of those may
have slightly increased to eat
non-animal products a lot more will be
eating animal products
yes I think that's exactly right
um that is what's happened uh we in some
countries you know uh meat consumption
is stable or even falling it's fallen in
Germany and in Sweden in recent years
but
um it's growing in those countries where
meat consumption used to be low
um and so we are certainly getting more
meat being produced
for the people who aren't familiar with
the ideas in animal Liberation what's
the key overview of your argument what
makes it uh different or novel or unique
well my argument is not based on the
idea that we should love animals or have
uh warm feelings to them it's based on
the idea that this is a major ethical
issue a major ethical wrong that we are
doing to those who are not members of
our species
and I argue that the kind of wrong is
analogous to the more familiar wrongs
that we have done in the past and to
some extent are still doing such as
racism and sexism so in saying that I'm
not comparing the experience of animals
to those of blacks or women but I am
saying that what these phenomena have in
common is that there is a a dominant
group
um
it might have been those of European
descent who went to Africa to buy slaves
or capture slaves and enslave them it
might be men who uh were able to take
power from women and essentially to make
women into into their property
um and in this case of course it's
humans as a whole
who do exactly that with animals animals
legally are property
um everywhere in the world of you know
domestic animals uh and uh we although
we may treat our companion animals
reasonably well with the animals that we
are raising for food or using as tools
for research in Laboratories they are
just things for us to use they are means
to our ends and we don't give their
interests consideration and as long as a
being can feel pain
that being has interest that we ought to
be taking into account and the fact that
they're not members of our species
doesn't in any way justify us
disregarding those interests is the goal
here to reduce suffering then
primarily the goal is to reduce
suffering yes
um it's not a matter of Rights
particularly it's not specifically
talking about the wrongness of killing
it's focused much more on the fact that
any being capable of feeling pain
has interests
um particularly interest in not
suffering and that's an interest that we
violate on an absolutely vast scale
we're talking about hundreds of billions
of animals that humans cause suffering
to by the conditions in which they raise
them each year
in your opinion do some animals have a
different capacity for suffering
yes I think the capacities for suffering
vary with the nature of the species
that's certainly true and we don't have
great ways of comparing the suffering
essentially I suppose we see it more
closely in those non-human animals who
either are seem to be like us because
they're closely related to us like
chimpanzees and bonobos and and
orangutans and so on
um or in those animals with whom we live
like dogs and cats and some people can
be very close to Horses of course so
there we recognize it quite well we
don't recognize it nearly so well in
chickens and fish for example but we do
now have and this is another important
difference between 1975
we do now have a growing body of
scientific research on
the capacities of non-human animals to
feel pain which animals feel pain what
kinds of things cause them to suffer so
we know a lot more about that than we we
did before
um but we certainly don't know
everything and if you move to a species
very different from us like an octopus
although the behavior of the octopus
shows intelligence and ability to solve
problems it's not easy for us to know
what an octopus is really feeling but it
does seem like it's a conscious being is
likely to be feeling pain and likely to
be able to suffer
if it's the case that different animals
perhaps have different capacities for
suffering does this mean that there's a
hierarchy with which we should care
about the suffering of different animals
a human should be placed above that of a
pig should be placed above that of a
vole should be placed above that of a
aphid
well um I wouldn't put it quite like
that
um I think that
there isn't a hierarchy in in the sense
that similar amounts of pain are
similarly important whether they're the
pain of a human or any of the animals
you just mentioned the question is
what do we regard as similar amounts of
pain and how do we know but
um uh you know I I don't think that
there's a kind of hierarchy of moral
status I think that there are just
questions that we need to ask about what
do different species feel what do we
know about the field and you know some
species may feel pain more acutely than
we do after all we know that many
species have much more acute sense of
smell dogs do they may have more acute
Vision Raptors you know have incredibly
sharp Vision so
it's hard to say you know you can't
really say well humans just feel more
pain than any other animal
um that's unlikely uh but yes we could
say well
some animals you know don't have enough
neurons really perhaps to feel pain so
you know maybe some of the insects don't
feel pain and are more kind of like
miniature robots you know maybe I I
don't know but but that's possible
yeah I understand I think uh oysters
like bivalves and and stuff like that
there's some
well I guess skepticism around whether
or not they can feel pretty much
anything at all
yes I'm skeptical about oysters because
you know pain evolves
so as a warning signal a signal of of
danger
um and beings that uh then have this
capacity for pain can move away from
that danger and Escape it badon oyster
doesn't move
um oyster just sits on a on a rock
basically and um you know so it's it's
hard to see why an oyster would have
evolved a capacity for pain
um given that you know there's there's
some cost to having those those
capacities you have to have uh some
neural matter and uh that has to you
know be fed and and whatever kept going
so yeah I I don't have any objective to
eating oysters
um you know because I don't think
they're they're sentient beings that's
that's a good example of an animal that
uh I don't think can feel pain
what would you say to the people who
believe that humans are the ones that
are guiding this planet why should I
care about the suffering of some
non-human animal I can care if another
human suffers because they're a a
complex creature like me but animals are
being bred they've always been bred for
a very long time for our consumption
this is the way that it's always been
why should we be bothered about the
suffering of other animals
well um I don't think the fact that we
uh are dominant is a reason for
discounting their interests and that was
also true of Europeans for example with
their more advanced technology their
guns so on that that we don't feel that
that justified them in uh dominating
other animals uh as for the fact that
you know it's always been like this
that's a very uh common conservative
argument uh but you could also you know
men could certainly have always said
that uh well you know men have been the
leaders of societies
um you know women have needed men's
permission to do things to who they
marry to um to have any possessions even
you know even in the 19th century in
England uh a married woman did not own
any property whatever property she
brought into the marriage uh on the day
they were married belonging to her
husband so um you know if one could have
said well it's been like this for a very
long time but we certainly don't think
that that justifies that arrangement
yeah the uh marital naturalistic fallacy
perhaps right yes I think that's what it
is yeah
um
what is the typical life like of an
animal that will arrive on somebody's
plate in 2023 what are some of the
numbers that are involved in sort of
some of the experiences
well the animals who we raise in the
largest numbers are are fish and I'm not
now talking about those fish who are
captured wild from the oceans I'm
talking about fish we raise in uh
commercial fish I wouldn't really call
them Farms commercial Fish Production
um and a recent estimate of that is 124
billion fish raised every year
um and and they are very closely
confined they are in small you know
ponds or Nets
um they're some of them like salmon have
an instinct to swim across the oceans uh
and uh they don't have any kind of
Humane Slaughter uh the other thing
that's worth noting particularly uh you
know suppose you buy a salmon
um farm salmon is most salmon are
nowadays
um
you're not responsible just for the life
and death of that salmon that salmon had
to be fed and the salmon is carnivorous
so trawlers had to go in in the ocean
and catch fish to be ground up low value
fish to be ground up into pellets to be
fed to that salmon and an estimate that
I've seen says that every salmon by the
time they're ready to be killed and sold
has consumed uh 147 other fish in total
so you're responsible for close to 150
fish being killed by the one salmon that
you buy
um in next in terms of numbers is
chicken
and something like 70 billion chicken
are raised worldwide each year these
chicken are sold very young they've been
bred to grow extremely fast so they
reach the weight that the chicken you
buy in the supermarket in something like
six weeks so really they're babies but
there's a problem with the fact that
they are bred to grow so fast uh or
several problems they suffer from bone
deformities because they put on weight
they're incredibly obese and their bones
are still immature
uh and one of the problems is that their
legs May collapse under them so the
industry
accepts something like five percent
mortality in these young birds one in 20
will die and those deaths may be caused
by the fact that their legs have
collapsed under them they can no longer
walk to food or water
um nobody is going to pay them
individual attention it's just not worth
the cost they're too cheap there's 20
000 birds in a single shed
um somebody might walk through the shed
and pick up the corpses after they've
died but they won't get any individual
help if their legs do collapse under
them and even those whose legs manage to
keep them uh standing until they're
ready that six weeks they're ready to be
rounded up for Slaughter
experts who've looked at this have said
that they are in pain for the last two
weeks because their body weight it hurts
them just to stand but they can't really
sit down either because they're living
on a kind of a litter that is full of
their droppings of these twenty thousand
birds and maybe previous batch of birds
their droppings are just left on the
floor of the shed and bird droppings are
strongly alkaline so when they mix with
air and with moisture they form a
caustic solution so if they were to
spend long time sitting on this litter
they would actually get caustic burns on
their thighs uh so they can't really do
that either
um you know one Observer a veterinarian
said it's like somebody with arthritis
who's forced to stand uh you know all
day or for the last uh 20 of their life
so I think you know that's really a
again a way of bringing up animals that
um does takes no account of their
well-being their suffering if it did we
wouldn't breed birds that are so
unsuited to um
to the kind of thing that they are
except for the fact that they put on
weight quickly and you can make more
money out of a faster growing bird than
a slower growing bird what comes next
which animals after the chickens
uh well I think pigs would be the the
next in terms of of quantity
um and that's particularly so in China
China is now the world's largest
producer of pigs although countries like
the United States have a lot of pigs as
well
um but uh you know pigs are also almost
all kept indoors nowadays uh the uh
they're also bred to grow very fast
they're closely confined in pens uh the
pigs that whose meat uh you know pork or
ham or bacon you actually buy will have
been kept in in small groups
um but always indoors and with little
room to move around the the worst
situation is their mothers the the
breeding sours whose role is just to
produce litter after litter of piglets
and they are still quite commonly kept
in individual crates or stalls just
metal bars too narrow for them to turn
around and uh they're
they've got no straw to bed down in
there either on concrete floors or on
metal slats because that's the easiest
and cheapest way to hose off the manure
uh so they have nothing to do these are
you know pigs are very intelligent
animals and uh comparable to dogs and
yet they just locked up all day uh they
have nothing to do except uh they do get
fed and then maybe they consume their
their food for half an hour or so and
that's it
um and if anybody kept a dog like that
in in conditions where a dog couldn't
run around or even turn around uh
everybody would say that's cruel they
ought to be prosecuted but because these
are pigs because they come under
commercial farming laws which typically
um allow these practices uh not as I
said not in the European Union and not
in the United Kingdom not in California
but in the states of the United States
where most of the pigs are reared States
like Iowa or Nebraska or North Carolina
there's no such laws preventing them
being kept in this way and in China
there's there's no real animal welfare
laws for farmed animal at all there are
some laws relating to how they can be
slaughtered but there's nothing no
National laws about how they can be
reared so I've seen photos of just vast
sheds with rows and rows of these sounds
standing in those stalls
again just to reiterate here your
position isn't that we should
be cuddly towards animals because
they're cute and they're nice and
they're supposed to be walking around on
a farmyard it's that there is an
Associated amount of suffering that goes
along with this and there is no reason
that we as humans shouldn't care about
the suffering of other animals that are
on this planet especially I would
imagine animals that we have brought
into this world ourselves
right we're fully responsible clearly
for their welfare we do that very
deliberately bring them into the world
and then put them in these conditions
um and that is really what I'm objecting
to I'll also add that this is not an
efficient way of feeding people some
people will say well the world's
population is growing you know we need
to feed them we've got to do this but
the truth is just the reverse this is a
waste of food because when you take
animals off the fields where they might
get at least some of the food by
themselves then um you have to feed them
and to feed them I've already mentioned
with the fish you have to go out and
catch fish and grind them up for the
carnivorous fish we we Farm anyway and
for the chickens and pigs
we have to grow grains or grow soybeans
which we could eat ourselves and uh feed
feed them to the animals and in the
process the animal wastes most of the
food value because the animal has to
keep their body warm you burn up
calories just to keep your body warm and
even if they are very confined and can't
really move around they still waste it
varies a bit according to species but if
we're talking about feeding grains to
cattle they waste at least 90 percent of
the food value if we're talking about
pigs they probably weigh something like
60 to 70 percent of the food value if
we're talking about chickens because
they grow so fast they're a little more
efficient they've perhaps waste
two-thirds of the food value we get one
third back so
uh yeah it's um it's not a good way of
feeding the world it's not a good way of
preserving the planet what about the
role of milk or eggs or cheese
right yes well um the egg-laying hens uh
again uh
in those places I mentioned the European
Union and some a few states of the
United States they can't be kept in the
wire cages that otherwise say the
majority of U.S hens are kept in uh
these very narrow wire cages where they
can't stretch their wings
um and uh uh so but even even where
they're not kept in cages they can still
be very crowded
um and you know I think it you could say
that in genuinely free-range egg
production where the eggs where the hens
are actually a large free to roam
outside
um and have grass that they can
yeah you use and they can pack at
insects in the grass or look for worms
or something like that you know yes you
can do that and you can produce eggs
they're more expensive but you can
produce eggs that way but the
overwhelming majority of eggs come from
hens who never go outside
um and as I say in in many countries the
majority are still in cages
with dairy um there has again been a big
move to intensify Dairy to produce have
large dairies the traditional dairy farm
maybe had 50 cows maybe 100 200 Cars
would have been a decent sized dairy
farm and they were able to go out each
day on on grass and Grays and that's not
too bad a life in itself
but the larger fans with a thousand or
more cars
they essentially keep them in in stalls
and they bring food to them but the
other big problem with with dairy
products which many people don't really
think of is that the dairy cows have to
be made pregnant at regular intervals to
keep producing milk so roughly every
year the cow will give birth to a calf
and uh the calf is taken away from the
cow within hours of birth because
otherwise the calf will drink the milk
that the producers want to sell so so
the separation of the cow and and her
calf is a painful process for both of
them there's a very strong bond between
cows and their calves and you know Dairy
Farmers have acknowledged that sometimes
when they're taking the calf away and
then the cow calls for that car for
hours and hours and sometimes even when
the cow comes if the calf was taken away
at a particular spot and the cow is
taken past that spot the cow will stop
and will call for a calf she remembers
the calf being taken away and the fate
of the calf isn't good either if if the
calf is female she may be raised as a
dairy cow herself but if the calf is
male she's likely to go so he is likely
to go into the veal industry or possibly
be raised for hamburger but dairy dairy
cows you know aren't really very good
for meat production they're not bred for
that I imagine that male chicks are
similarly useless
the male chicks of the laying breeds the
egg laying breeds yes and they are
generally just thrown into a kind of a
grinder which grinds them up immediately
after the after they're they're hatched
and their their sex is selected the
females are put on one side and the
males get ground up
there are some moves in Europe to
develop technologies that um either
enable you to sex the egg and therefore
destroy the egg before the chick is
hatched or even
um
enable it make it possible that the hand
will only lay eggs of females and that
would solve the problem of the male
chicks uh and I say I think Germany and
France are trying to legislate at least
for the uh sexing in the in the egg
rather than the chick to prevent the
suffering of these millions of male
chicks that get ground up uh but in the
United States that isn't being done yet
and then you know here where I'm in
Australia it's not being done either I
imagine that one of the most common
objections after you put forward a case
like that and you know by the sounds of
things the life of these animals isn't
tremendously enjoyable I don't think
that anyone even the most Ardent
meat-eater would say yeah I'm really
proud of being part of a system that
causes animals to go through that kind
of situation but there are ways that we
can do this we can look at regenerative
farming we can ensure that chickens not
only are free range but have a natural
range they've got tons of hectares that
they can go over is there a problem with
eating an egg if it's been created by a
chicken that's had a fantastic life
that's been looked after that's been
cared for protected from foxes the same
thing goes for I'm sure there is a way
that you can get milk from a cow that
doesn't involve the emotional turmoil
that they go through
in your opinion are there any ways that
you can do ethical animal farming
there are ways that I think can be
regarded as ethical
um you can have a debate about whether
they are as ethical or ethical enough to
eat those products but but I think the
debate is is an ongoing one and a
reasonable one so while I'm not going to
say I endorse those forms of animal
production I am going to say
I don't have a you know a conclusive
objection to saying that they're wrong
or that they shouldn't be done so for
people who want to continue to eat
animal products if they conscientiously
search out those products
I'm prepared to say yes they're they're
trying to live an ethical life uh and
and that's a reasonable attempt to do so
um they'll probably be able to succeed
with with free-range eggs depending a
little bit where they're living
um but you know there are free range
eggs being sold in most countries
labeled as such uh you may need to check
up on how many hens there are per
hectare or acre
but it's possible uh don't kid
yourselves that the hens will have a
long life because once they stop laying
which is you know well before the normal
they would normally die
um they will be killed I don't think
many commercial producers will keep
feeding hens who lay no eggs
um the male chicks may still get killed
that's another issue
um and uh but with the dairy products
it's really really hard to find Dairy
Producers who leave their care they cut
their calves with their cats
um in animal Liberation now I think I
mentioned three of them one in England
one in Germany and one here in Australia
uh the dairy products are a lot more
expensive
um
but um yeah if people can do that
um then okay uh still question of if if
the cows are producing male calves uh
what are you going to do with them are
you going to keep them
um but at least the Australian producer
that I've had some contact with
um uses uh sperm selection they use
artificial insemination for producing
the calves and they select the sperm and
they get very very few male cows so
that's one way of dealing with that
um I think their their milk is about
three times as expensive as milk from
standard commercial producers so you
have to be prepared to pay for it but if
you really want to continue to eat
animal products and you want to have an
ethical relationship with animals
um I guess that's one way of doing it
think about how much more tasty all of
that morality is going to be though
that's really going to add on to the
flavor profile yeah and I think people
will appreciate it more that's true you
know um I'm old enough to uh remember
when I was a child when chicken was a
treat because it was expensive and uh
you know in my family you got it on your
birthday
um and you know it did it did seem
something special then
um I don't think many people think that
chicken is a special treat now
um but maybe if you only eat animal
products from really animals who have
really good lives and they're killed
without pain and suffering uh you would
eat these animal products quite rarely
and you would think of them as a special
treat and you would enjoy them more
perhaps one of the
uh progressions that I've seen from some
of the more uh militant
corners of the veganism movement is
saying that owning any type of pet would
be something which is unethical as well
I think a lot of people
struggle to understand how uh you know
owning a dog that most people see not
only is just uh something that they care
about but literally a part of the family
these people you know treat them as if
they're essentially a surrogate child in
fact some people decide not to have
children in place of a ton of dogs or
cats what is your position on the owning
of pets
uh I don't discourage people having I
prefer to think of them as companion
animals but I don't discourage people
from living with companion animals
um I don't like you know you said owning
them well that is the legal situation of
course now I'd I'd rather think of them
as you said as members of the family and
companions
um I I don't think you would be able to
own them in the same way that you don't
own your son or daughter exactly yes
that's right
um but uh I do think that you know many
people with companion animals do give
them good and rewarding lives obviously
not everybody but but many do and it's
also I think important for our
understanding of non-human animals uh I
already mentioned earlier that people
who live with dogs or cats have a sense
that uh you know what they're like that
they're complex beings that they not
only feel pain if you tread on their
paws but they have uh you know emotional
suffering when they're they're bored
when you leave them alone at home at
least dogs aren't
um and uh you know they welcome you when
you come home and they love to go for a
run and there's a lot of things that we
learn about animals through being close
to a dog or a cat or a horse
um and and that has led many people
on to appreciating that the way they're
treating or the way they're complicit in
the treatment of uh pigs and and cows
and chickens uh is wrong
um one of the
perhaps you know the leading animal
Advocate and strategist of the animal
movement in the United States in the
last quarter of the 20th century it was
a man called Henry Spira who
um was a close friend of mine and and he
was somebody he was always like for
Progressive causes he marched for civil
rights in the American South
um he was a merchant Seaman and joined a
reformist union to try to improve
conditions for workers after the Cuban
Revolution he went there to see it
himself what was happening but he had no
thoughts about animals until a friend of
his was going overseas said hey look
after my cat I've got no one else to
look after my cat here's a cat
um and and the cat basically Charmed him
as he says and suddenly he had this
Epiphany that Harry was patting one
animal and sticking a knife and fork
into another
um and uh was that something wrong with
that and he happened to come across my
animal Liberation at the same time and
that combination started him off on a
career that really improved lives for
many animals have you considered the
suffering of wild animals and whether
it's our duty to somehow step in and I
mean really write that
I have considered that
um I would say I was prompted to
consider it by some other philosophers
who started thinking about that issue I
didn't really think much about it in the
early versions of the book but I have a
few pages about it in animal Liberation
now
uh I certainly think that we should
consider the interests of wild animals
and there are relatively simple things
that we can do
um the largest number of wild animals we
harm is again fish and we harm them by
hauling them out of the ocean in uh and
letting them die in Cruel conditions
because you know they will suffocate in
nets for example or
um die slowly so uh and we're
overfishing the oceans so avoiding uh
wild caught fish is good for wild
animals and good for the sustainability
of the oceans
um
and I think also things like um trying
to install a glass that birds won't fly
into that's another major killer of
animals uh and I think you know if you
do have a cat
um keeping your cat indoors at least at
night if not all the time depending
where you live is important for wild
animals because although you know many
cat lovers deny it
um there's very strong evidence that
pretty much any cat left outside
especially at night becomes a predator
and kills uh you know small animals
small birds uh small rodents
um so yeah keeping keeping your cat
indoors at night is a good way of
reducing the suffering of wild animals
if that's the case and you lived in an
area let's say that was overrun with
wild pigs there are some places in
America that have this problem and some
people get in big helicopters with 50
cal machine guns on the side of them and
just chew through Reams and Reams and
reams of animals
how do you balance the ethical decision
there if these animals were left they
would destroy an ecosystem which
Downstream from that has a ton of other
animals that live in it the only
interjection that we can make is to kill
them but by doing that you're killing an
animal in a pretty inhumane way on the
side of a gunship loaded with a belt-fed
machine gun
yeah
um we have similar problems with wild
animals in Australia too uh look I I
respect the environmental values that we
want to preserve and uh it's our fault
for having introduced these uh
non-native species and uh they've
escaped or they've sometimes they've
been deliberately released to breed and
and we've created this Havoc
um it's obviously not the fault of the
pigs but um
I agree with those who think that uh you
know there are at least some situations
where we can't just let it go
um I would like to see more Humane ways
of dealing with a problem than the
helicopter gunships that you mentioned
uh
so
uh ideally we would put some research
into developing a bait that will
sterilize the animals and therefore that
would deal with the problem more
humanely over the long term interesting
so yeah I mean
in a very small scale that can be done
there's a couple of islands uh in off
the the Delmarva Peninsula in Maryland
uh cincatika and Assateague I think
they're called
um where there was a problem with feral
horses uh feral ponies and and people
care more about horses than they do
about pigs so uh when people said we
need to shoot all these ponies uh people
said no you can't do that
um and then they they did find ways of
of sterilizing them um but uh you know
on a large scale over large territory uh
you probably can't can't do that very
easily at the moment but uh yeah you
might be able to develop a bait that the
pigs would take that the native animals
would not take
um and that would sterilize them
yeah it's a it's a fascinating decision
criteria there so I I got introduced to
your uh position probably about four or
five years ago from a friend and I am a
me teacher I still am now but it's been
by far for me the most compelling
consideration around my consumption of
animals where is it being sourced from
how do I feel about eating it even
little things I know that as a
utilitarian this probably doesn't count
but having a little bit more reverence
for the food that you eat and for where
it's come from
um
has been something that was that was
changed upon understanding a more moral
and ethical framework as opposed to a
screechy person who was shouting about
how terrible you are because and then
some placard that gets waved in your
face it seemed like a much more scalable
um uh way of thinking about Animal
Welfare
given the fact that the net outcome that
you're looking for is to just reduce
animal suffering
and you've been talking about this for
nearly 50 years and are now revisiting
it again
what do you think about the modern
iteration of the veganism movement and
its sort of many hydra-headed uh version
of of How It's progressed what have you
observed that's been that's been
interesting being on the front lines of
this for so long
yeah there are a lot of different
tactics used
um and uh
it's hard to know which tactics are the
most effective that's a difficult
problem in in social science research to
work out what influences people
um I I'm perfectly clear that that
really violent actions just put people
off and give give the whole movement a
bad name and I'm glad that they seem to
have ceased there was a period in the
80s when some activists were using
violence and you know relatively little
I mean there was a lot of publicity
about it
um the number of people who were hurt by
it was you could count on the fingers of
your hand I think
um but uh still it was not a good uh
thing to be doing for an ethical
movement
um and the sort of in your face thing I
guess you know yes people find it
offensive we don't know whether it gets
them to think in the end or not but um
I've been impressed by the recent use of
uh what's called open rescue techniques
where people have gone into factory
farms and videoed what's going on there
and if they've seen particularly ill
animals or particularly maltreated
animals that looked like they were not
going to survive very long anyway
they've rescued them they've taken them
at they've taken them through a vet
um if if the vet says uh no this animal
isn't going to live then uh they put
them down but otherwise they treat them
to try to help them and then they show
uh the video footage and they show their
individual animals because then people
can focus on individuals
um and it's interesting that the uh
there's been a move to prosecute these
people
um because after all they are taking
property pigs pigs or chickens whatever
they are their property
um and there have been a couple of
recent cases where the prosecution has
badly backfired uh so uh
two two Rescuers took pigs from a farm
in Utah and uh they were put on trial on
felony theft charges I think they could
have spent five years in in prison uh
and they didn't deny that they'd taken
the pigs
um but the jury and and this is you know
Utah's a fairly conservative State and
they were in a rural part of the state
you'd expect to be more conservative
more farm friendly but the jury refused
to convict them uh and then there was a
second case in California after that too
so it's a way of getting
the randomly selected members of the
public on the jury to express their view
of what's going on in these places and
it's clear that they don't like it
in your opinion is it moral to convince
people to become vegan through an
immoral method so something like uh
lying to them or emotional coercion or
something like that
no I don't think it is and I think it's
likely to backfire because uh you know
there will be people who will expose
what's going on and let's say that it
didn't in this situation let's say it
didn't backfire let's say that the
outcome was that nobody got rumbled but
on route to doing it it was an immoral
means to a moral end in your view well
as a utilitarian I I do think that it is
sometimes Justified to do things that
would not be right in themselves
but when they lead to importantly good
ends can be justified so if you're
talking hypothetically
um I think that could be justified if
you're talking about would I advise uh a
vegan activist to use those methods the
answer is no because you know we can't
specify that it is only going to have
the good consequences and not have the
bad consequences yeah it's um
it's an interesting an interesting
consideration and one that I've spoken
to a bunch of different friends about
you mentioned before we discussed this
um kind of spectrum I suppose between
factory farming and regenerative farming
and living at home with a chicken that
lives in the backyard or whatever it
seems to me that um factory farming is
the thin end of the wedge that again
most people that hear the stories about
the kind of experiences that you've just
described from animals very few of them
are going to be Arden proud flag waving
supporters of it
um it does seem like that gets spread
out to Inc to cover absolutely
everything that it's not just the
factory farming it's also the
regenerative farming and lots of people
I think are changing their eating habits
because of a fear of environmental
impact as well as just what's happening
to animals and emotive imagery and stuff
like that in your opinion do you think
it's a
almost a failing of moral philosophy to
have sufficient impact that you need to
rely on concerns about climate change
and so on and so forth should it be the
case that we are able to motivate humans
morally without having to layer on top
multiple different arguments
it should be the case that the argument
against inflicting suffering on animals
is sufficient to persuade people
um yes ideally that would be the case
um when I
Road and released uh and the first
version of animal Liberation in 1975
I thought that this argument was so
obvious and compelling that it would
have that effect
um that was a bit naive
um but uh
um ideally it would if we were more
rational if we were more moved by ethics
more ethical I'm sure it would uh but
um you know in saying that I think the
arguments about not eating meat because
of climate change are also ethical
arguments
um they're not appealing to
self-interest really because you know
from self-interest to point of view what
I would like is to keep doing what I
like enjoy doing and hope that everyone
else will stop doing these things that
will have bad effects
yeah yeah it's the tragedy of the
commons exactly so um So to avoid the
tragedy of the commons you either need
government regulation
um or you need individual ethical action
we don't have government regulation
that's taking the right stand on
Industrial animal production yet
um so we need ethical action why do you
think it is the case that
the argument you put forward 50 years
ago that you thought as soon as
everybody hears this evidently they
they're going to change their ways this
is going to be the beginning of a kind
of diet virus that's going to cause
everybody to become ethical why why why
hasn't that convinced more people
I think it's just that uh eating habits
uh go very deep and are hard to change I
mean the contrast here would be with
some other ethical change like
um the dramatic Improvement in attitudes
towards uh gays and bisexual people and
lesbians and so on
um which you know I don't think many
people so in the year 2000 I don't think
many people thought that within the next
20 years
a lot of countries would accept not only
that we shouldn't prosecute uh guys for
their sexual acts but that we should
allow them to marry in this exactly the
same way as we allow heterosexuals to
marry
um that was a dramatic change but
there's less at stake for you know most
people don't have very much at stake
they have an attitude but they don't
feel I'm going to have to change my
lives my life it's the thing that you
need to be gay it's saying that you need
to align it's not saying you need to
marry someone of your same sex if people
tried that they would not get very far
um but uh the the animal movement of the
case that I was putting forward was
saying you need to change what you eat
um and that's much more difficult
you know for a whole lot of reasons I
mean there may be some sort of we evolve
to have a taste for meat because that's
a very dense nutrient that was available
to our ancestors and those that ate it
did better than those that didn't but
because that's not the case anymore
today it's it's more of a health risk
um or it may be that it's it's embedded
in our culture and you know we think oh
but if I stopped eating meat
I wouldn't have the traditional
Thanksgiving turkey or uh whatever other
you know wouldn't Slaughter the the
sheep for the Feast of the eyed
um so so meat is is culturally embedded
in uh in ways that make it harder to
change and there's also that sense of a
lot of people say well you know
their family eats meat what are they
going to do when they go and eat with
them
um they are they going to tell their
friends that they should stop eating
meat isn't that being a bit
self-righteous
um it's you know we're fairly conformist
in that uh there are some people who are
prepared to say
no I'm gonna break with that tradition
and uh be it
a non-conformist but I think there are a
lot of people who don't want to be among
the leaders of the change and would
rather follow than lead
given that vegetables and vegan products
no matter how correctly they're sourced
are also associated with an increase in
death and suffering of animals stuff
that happens just during harvesting and
so on and so forth it's inevitable that
that's going to end up happening
does this not mean that there is a moral
obligation for every human to try and
limit their calorie consumption
to as little as possible I shouldn't eat
one calorie more than I should I should
also eat a vegan diet but that vegan
diet shouldn't be
a single calorie over because as soon as
I do that is unnecessarily impacting
animal life Upstream
I think if you really start worrying
about every calorie you're going to go
crazy and you're not going to be very
effective in doing anything else
um
so I think that's you know that's some
sort of saintly ideal if you like and
it's similar to arguments that I've put
forward in relation to Global poverty
um again you know a long time ago when I
was perhaps a little
too much of a demanding ethicist that we
should give away all of our assets until
we reach the point of marginal utility
and until we reach the point at which
sharing something or giving something
more to a person in extreme poverty
would lower us to the same level of
poverty or suffering as the person we
were helping
um that's also I think
um you know not a realistic ethic to put
forward and as a consequentialist I want
to put forward ethical views that will
achieve the maximum benefits so I no
longer make that argument in terms of of
how much we should give away I suggest
instead say in my book the life you can
save I suggest more reasonable
percentages of incomes that scale up as
you earn more and similarly I think in
terms of you know trying to get people
to move towards uh a vegan diet or at
least a more conscientiously ethical
diet that has concern for what animal is
experiencing I think saying you can't
eat a single calorie over what you need
to maintain your body is uh is is not
going to work
for the people like me who aren't
philosophy pilled
talking about the blending of the
position of a utilitarian with that of a
consequentialist
am I right in thinking that a
utilitarian would be looking to maximize
the utility from whatever the choices or
the framework is that's being put
forward but the consequentialist
understands that there are real world
restrictions on that that need to be
filtered through so it's is it almost
like a blending of the two positions
no I don't think that's quite right I
think that utilitarians will also want
to produce the best consequences uh you
know
utilitarianism is a version of
consequentialism consequentialism is the
genus utilitarianism is the species and
the difference between them is not
um their attitudes to what's realistic
or what's not it's their attitude to
what are the consequences that we want
to maximize that we want to focus on the
utilitarian will say the consequences
are uh well-being the well-being of all
of those capable of having a well-being
which means in my view all sentient
creatures and we want them to suffer as
little pain as possible to to suffer as
little uh to experience as much pleasure
to be as happy as possible that's the
utilitarian view the consequentialist
will say I agree that whether an action
is right or wrong depends on its
consequences but I don't think that
well-being is the only consequence that
matters I think it's for example it's
good that people should have greater
knowledge whether they use that
knowledge to enhance well-being or not I
think it's important that people should
be free whether they use their freedom
in ways that enhance well-being or not
um and you know then there's a whole
list and that's the thing about
consequentialists in general once you
move away from specifically utilitarian
consequences there are about 50 things
that people have put on lists that they
think of as intrinsically good and they
want to maximize and everybody then
takes their pick of these 50 things as
to which are the ones that I want to
maximize and and why and and then you
have to say well are you sure this is
really good in itself you sure like with
knowledge you sure knowledge isn't good
because it can help us to improve
well-being you're sure that just having
additional knowledge is good even if has
no further consequences those are the
kinds of debates that they then have to
have
could you imagine a situation in which a
human who was bought into the world of
uh ethical veganism and was talking
about this sort of stuff on the internet
let's say or or on any kind of platform
but was struggling to
eat a sufficiently well-balanced diet
that allowed them to maximize the impact
that they could have on the world
existed so this person believes in the
precepts of it and is talking about it
online and is doing it in a very
compelling way and encouraging other
people to consider their approach to
what their diet looks like too but their
individual
um challenges that they're facing with
their own health mean that they then
consider moving from a vegan to a
meat-based diet now whilst they're on
this meat-based diet they're going to
continue talking to the world and
encouraging as many people as possible
would it be a an ethical position for
that person to hold to say look I'm
going to do something personally which I
would see as unethical or immoral in
order to encourage and maximize the
impact that I can have on the rest of
the world
yeah I've actually had that's not a
hypothetical I've had people come to me
and say things
somewhat similar to that
um I think you know it took me a while
to accept this because I've always felt
great on uh vegetarian and vegan diets
um and others that I know have too but
um there are some people who seem to
have a different Constitution and who
don't do well uh certainly not on an
exclusively vegan diet so if you are one
of those people and but you see the
point of the cause
um yeah I would say to preserve your
health and to maintain the ability to be
an active Force for good in the world
um you should
seek out those animal products that will
be sufficient to maintain your your
health and vigor and will do the least
harm to animals to the climate and so on
so for example we were talking earlier
about free-range eggs from from hens who
are genuinely free range and have grass
to range around on uh
um I think that's that's an example of
something that I would see as doing
minimizing harm providing some animal
protein and maybe that's enough for some
people you know if it's not then they
need to look further but they always
need to think about who is where can I
get this product
in a way where the animals are really
cared for well uh where the greenhouse
gases are not great or offset
um so yeah those are the sorts of
questions and I appreciate that a small
number of people may need to do that to
keep active and vigorous loads of
muscles just tons but generally you
don't need messy muscles
oh muscles I see those muscles right so
yeah eating enough animal products to
build up their muscles and in fact yes
you could do that yes that would be uh
go to town go to town on the buy valves
okay so um obviously one of the things
that you've done uh nearly 50 years
between both between this version and
the first version of this the cultural
climate has changed an awful lot during
that time the type of arguments that can
be made that are accepted widely uh or
even accepted not so widely uh have
changed a good bit what were some of the
um elements that you had to remove from
the book in order to make it more
palatable for a 2023 audience
well um a very glaring example of that
was that in the first version of the
book
um I wanted to make the point at the
beginning that this book was not written
for animal lovers and that I didn't
consider myself an animal lover and that
was raising a major ethical issue and to
make that point I used a parallel
between uh this issue and uh or or the
way that I was approaching this issue
and the way that uh whites in the 1950s
and 60s who were supportive of the
movement against racial segregation in
the American South
um would go down to march with uh
Blackson assass for you know against
segregation of schools or universities
or buses or restaurants or whatever
and uh to make the point that I know I
was not an animal lover I said I quoted
uh an epithet that was often used by
white racists so against these by white
Southern racist against these
Northerners who came down to help them
and they used the n-word to suggest that
they loved the people that they were
helping
um and I and I had that in the first
edition I had that word in quotes
um it was a quote and I said it was a
racist who was saying this there was no
way at all in which I was endorsing the
use of that word
um but now that word has become such a
strong taboo that you can't even use it
in quotes in that sense and um so that
editor uh indicated that that they had
to go and I accepted that view yeah I
think if if no matter how
um
clean you want or how uh appropriately
you want to try and represent the
original material you're inevitably
gonna have to do that there's a couple
of other bits as well that I'd seen
um to do with uh men getting the ability
of men to have equal abortion rights or
the equal
um was it access to opportunity
something like that
yes that's right I was saying that yes I
was saying that to say that animals have
rights didn't mean that they had the
right to vote or something like that um
any more than
um to say that uh there's a right to
abortion means that men uh have equal
abortion rights with women or some
something like that I can't remember the
exact wording
um yes and uh of course now you can't
refer to pregnant women you should refer
to pregnant people uh as the Fraud's
conversation I still find that a little
strange I must say but well
thinking about this situation and this
is what particularly fascinated me about
it you're a man who is famous for his
cold analytical approach and you have
had to remove some very powerful
arguments that I've heard friends use
I've heard friends use that exact
argument
about the access to abortion and and
men's rights to abortion
you've had to remove some powerful
Arguments for the life of animals
because of modern sensitivities
is that I mean what what do you think
that says about our current ethical
position in the modern world
well I think it says that perhaps we're
we're too sensitive
um about some of these issues and we
we should be more prepared to face some
of these realities but
um I went along with the editor's
suggestions on on these issues because
this book is about a particular cause a
particular issue I want to attract as
wide support as I possibly can because
of the urgency to stop what we're doing
to uh to say hundreds of billions of
sentient creatures and damaging our
climate
um and I didn't want to get distracted
by a small side issue where people would
say oh hijacking I'm not going to buy
that book yeah I'm not going to read
that book you've got to decide which
Wars you can fight right you can't fight
all the wars at the same time yeah I
understand so one other
modern discussion that probably wasn't a
consideration when you first wrote this
book was Ai and over the last six months
we've seen a huge Resurgence in
discussions about it it kind of really
lulled you know Nick Bust from Super
intelligence was
2014 something like that I think and
that really kind of kicked off this
concern about pay-per-clip maximizers
and Alignment problems and machine
extrapolated volition
and then it went quiet for forever
because it didn't seem like AI was
making any progress and then Chachi PT
comes out and everything goes ballistic
again have you considered the potential
for AI agents to suffer and our
obligations to them
yes absolutely um I have thought about
that and in fact with some others I'm
organizing a Princeton a conference at
Princeton University in uh October
um which will include that topic as well
as talking about the impact that AI is
having on animals which is significant
because uh some industrial Farms are now
being basically run by AI rather than
you know by individual humans in the
same way uh plus of course there's all
these decisions or dilemmas about
self-driving cars and do you program
them to Swerve to avoid the dog or only
to Swerve to avoid the child
um so I have been involved in AI ethical
questions and my answer to the question
you asked about uh
could there be conscious AI could AI be
a sentient being
um and if so what would moral status be
I think the answer is in principle AI
could be sentient or conscious I don't
think we have got close to that yet I
think that chat gbt uh sort of fools us
into thinking we're chatting with a
sentient being but when we understand
what it's actually doing and how it's
regurgitating some of the material that
it's fed on and how it adjusts uh I
think we realize that there's no reason
to postulate any Consciousness but if if
that did happen and in principle it's
possible to happen then we would need to
give that AI a moral status
um at least like that of animals and
depending on its cognitive abilities
maybe it would be closer to to that of
most humans
have you considered or thought of a way
in which an AI agent
would be able to convince you that it
was having a felt sense of an experience
because you can I mean
five-year-old girls have got dolls that
will cry if they're not picked up
sufficiently frequently nobody is
mistaking the doll for having the felt
experience of being lonely but you know
you roll it all the way down and it
seems to me I haven't thought about this
a lot but it seems to me that it would
be very difficult to
separate out AI agent
performing what emotions look like from
conscious agent experiencing them
basically is every AI just a p zombie in
disguise with with circuit boards
uh so far
um but uh yeah the question of how we're
going to know is is really an
interesting and important question
because uh you know many years ago Alan
Turing said uh if you can have a
conversation with the robot and you
don't know whether you're having a
conversation with a robot or with a real
person then we should assume it's
conscious but that is the case with chat
GPT I mean abstractable people into
thinking that so uh I don't and yet as I
say once you understand
what it's actually doing what it's
programmed to do I think you don't think
it's it's conscious now
um
the problem is that these AIS are
learning all the time developing all the
time and I think we're going to get it
into the situation where they're going
to be
producing other AI right that they're
they're getting to be smart enough to
design other systems and uh then we
won't really know how the other system
works in the way that we might know
about the ones so far
and uh
it'll be very difficult to deter whether
to tell whether it is conscious or not
um because it's not simply a matter of
of saying you know looking at the the
algorithms there because because it's
it's learning things and developing so
uh yeah I'm I'm not really an expert in
this field
um I've talked to some people who have
more expertise than me
um and I've started to see the
difficulty of this problem I had Stuart
Russell on the show 18 months ago and he
wrote human he's written everything he
wrote literally the textbook on AI it's
in some ungodly number of languages and
um he was saying
if you were a lot of the time uh YouTube
will be asked open up the algorithm show
us what the algorithm is doing or tell
us tell us how the algorithm works and
especially when you're looking at
something like YouTube his
argument was the engineers at YouTube
don't know what the YouTube algorithm is
doing it's got its own optimization
um function that it is aiming for it is
trying to maximize time on site and
click through and watch time and they
just set this bunch of parameters and
then it's run away and it is now
reinforcing okay let's do this a little
bit more let's change for that select
for this kind of video Once someone does
this then do this
and you realize that yeah I mean if
you've got recursive self-improving AI
that are creating either improving
themselves or creating further agents
that are their own uh progeny in one
form or another I mean you definitely
don't know two degrees removed but even
just one degree removed what you've
created after a sufficiently long amount
of time learning is probably not really
going to resemble what it was that you
made it in the first place so yeah
getting in there and going oh well you
know we'll just
see where's the emotion algorithm we
didn't put the emotion algorithm in here
therefore it can't you know the sadness
the sadness code doesn't exist within
this
I think it's a a really really and I
fundamentally to me that seems to be the
most interesting and the most
challenging question that's going to
come up about this at what point are we
going to say that an an AI agent
claiming Consciousness sentience the
ability to suffer etc etc
are we ever going to know because the
only reason really that you believe that
I have the capacity to suffer that if
you poke me with a pin that I'm not just
saying ow performatively because I know
that that's what you would do and
there's everybody else on the planet is
just some big robot that's been here to
Truman Show Truman Show Peter singer's
life for the last however many decades
the only reason is that we we kind of
have this Faith right between us and we
we believe that that's the case
very very difficult with no proof no one
has ever been an AI agent that has a
felt sense of this and we can't use our
theory of mind to to try and believe it
I think that's going to be I think
that's going to be the biggest challenge
that we face
yeah I think that's a huge challenge I
agree and I don't have an answer to it
um come on Peter I don't know how anyone
does but I say ai ai Liberation now
that's why that's what I've come for
um right well look Peter Singer ladies
and gentlemen Peter I really appreciate
you you have got a tour
of some kind that you are doing that
people can attend where is that and
when's it happening I do have a speaking
tour yes I'm going to be speaking in
Washington DC on May the 26th in Los
Angeles on the 29th in San Francisco on
the 30th of May and in in New York City
on June 1st and in London on June 4th
um and you can find that if you Google
uh an evening with Peter Singer and
maybe put in think Inc uh think and then
Inc which is the organization that is
organizing the tour you'll get
information and tickets and I would love
to see you all there and uh get a chance
to speak to you and to hear your
questions Peter I really appreciate you
thank you for today thanks very much
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace